what would you say is the most common
overused way to end a script what would
be what would that be what would be the
common way to end a script I don't think
there's a real common way I think I
think the I think the problems the
endings that are problematic and maybe a
better question I think it usually is
when you when a character does something
against their own motives the motives
that you've just defined for them
earlier in the movie that go against
their character so they do something
like that that a choice at the end that
makes it like wait a minute
that just happened like you don't expect
them to do something like that or you
know some something where there is some
sort of fantastic ending that doesn't
mean anything something that's
implausible that's something that is
unlikely again character doing something
unreasonable or circumstances I mean you
can look at get out get out was a
masterpiece and the only thing that was
probably problematic for some people and
this is a massive spoiler alert so if
you have not seen get out stop watching
this movie and if you're watching this
video you should have already watched
get out so we want to go and watch get
out and you can come back and watch this
movie so there's your spoiler alert but
the end of get out when his friend shows
up who's the security guard it seems
like something that was unreasonable and
not logical and I think he probably the
filmmaker probably recognized that but
he had built up so much goodwill with us
that I was willing to accept that a TSA
agent he was a TSA agent was able to
somehow find him and I and I suspended
my disbelief but that is a perfect
example of like a film that is a
masterpiece but even how to end it and I
believe his original ending was
something much darker
and and they decided not to do that and
so he came up with something else that
was probably he probably didn't choose
that original ending because of a logic
issue because he had so much control
over logic in that picture but at the
end he did choose something where he had
to suspend our disbelief a little bit
but when you're the Goodwill's been
built up by the writer so much and the
filmmaker storyteller then we see we can
sort of forgive it and we did sort of
forgive it some people maybe not but I I
did I said I said you know maybe that's
a little but it is in the realm of
possibility that the TSA guy could
somehow track him and find him
and I could let that go but so I think
the common problems all often involve
logic and characters doing something
motives and decisions that are out of
character and within the character wait
what would they do that why would they
do that why would they make the decision
and to get out of the movie so yeah
you